cautious condemnation for Justin Trudeau
on the missile strike into Poland near
the he nor British PM Mercy sunak would
assign blame for the attack
we shared a number of things with the
Ukrainian foreign minister but the
important thing is to allow the
investigations to go forward and find
out exactly what happened the Polish
attack led to a last second meeting at
the G7 with NATO countries joining as
well discussing the issue and that
meeting lasted about an hour right after
U.S President Joe Biden came out and
suggested the missile that hit Poland
didn't come from Russia there is
permanent information that contests that
I don't want to say that until we
completely investigate but it is a
I
i i i i i it's unlikely in the minds of
the trajectory that it was fired from
Russia but we'll we'll see based on what
we so far know uh this is most likely a
Ukrainian air defense
systems or missiles but again this is
not Ukraine's fault Russia Bears the
responsibility of what happened in uh in
in polyester because this is a direct
result of the ongoing War and the wave
of attacks from Russia against Ukraine
yesterday the one country that could
help end the war in Ukraine is China and
for the second day in a row Justin
Trudeau spoke with Chinese president Xi
Jinping at the closing session of the
G20 but this time the tone was terse she
complained directly to Trudeau about his
office sharing details of their previous
conversation everything we discusses
everything that has been discussed has
been leaked to the papers that's not
appropriate said SRI through a
translator Trudeau then cuts off The
Interpreter a senior Canadian government
source told reporters yesterday that
Trudeau raised the war in Ukraine North
Korea and Chinese interference was she
today Trudeau wouldn't say if the
interference you brought up was she was
the alleged Chinese interference that
Global News has reported took place in
the 2019 election I raised the issue of
interference with our citizens and
expressed that it's important that we
continue to have dialogue about that
there was some doubt that G20 leaders
wouldn't be able to agree on a final
communique in Bali but in the end it did
actually happen after Western leaders
agreed to water down their language on
the key topic of the summit the final
text says that only most G20 countries
condemn the war in Ukraine Mackenzie
gray Global News Bali Indonesia